[Musica]
che cosa c'entra il dna con i viaggi
provo a spiegarmelo sappiamo che la
scoperta del dna è un evento
straordinario per molti motivi non
ultimo perché ci ha permesso di mappare
i viaggi sin da quando l'uomo ha
iniziato a spostarsi dall'africa
centrale dove la nostra spesa e si è
manifestata fino agli angoli più remoti
del nostro pianeta
abbiamo così scoperto che le migrazioni
viaggi gli spostamenti sono la
caratteristica più comune ad ogni essere
umano siamo gente che si sposta e che si
è sempre spostata
oggi la fotografia accompagna i nostri
viaggi ed un modo per condividere
l'entusiasmo per ciò che si è visto e
vissuto all'inizio si va alla ricerca
della bella spiaggia bei panorami bei
monumenti ad esempio ecco il mio primo
viaggio in india dove sono andato alla
ricerca dei simboli tradizionali del
paese
poi però succede che si finisce attirati
da un mondo così diverso che per quanto
1 provi a descriverlo non si riesce
proprio a rendere l'idea
ma è proprio qui che qualcosa è cambiato
sapete quando si dice che ciò che rimane
veramente del viaggio sono le persone è
vero perché sono quelle che ti rimangono
dentro e quelle mi sono trovato
fotografare cercando di catturarne
l'essenza lo sguardo vedere dentro gli
occhi di chi ci guarda crea una
connessione intima con la loro vita e la
loro storia ma non sono certo bellezze
da cartolina sono bellezze diverse più
rare
ci sono tantissimi modi per raccontare
queste persone io ho scelto di
raccontarne la bellezza ho scelto di
trasmettere lo stupore che provo ogni
volta che viaggio condividendo la più
grande ricchezza degli esseri umani la
diversità
e se ci spingiamo sempre più lontano ci
si ritrova tra popoli etnia a noi
sconosciuti bisogna però riuscire ad
abbandonare i propri stereotipi le
proprie abitudini per riuscire a calarsi
completamente nella cultura che si
incontra la scelta di mostrare queste
persone attraverso una forte componente
estetica è perché penso che la bellezza
sia la chiave per far avvicinare sempre
più persone a questa realtà e attraverso
la condivisione dei miei scatti mi sono
accorto che funziona le persone si
incuriosiscono iniziato a chiedermi dove
sono questi luoghi come sono queste
persone quindi la fotografia aiuta
trasmettere i mille modi in cui la
bellezza si mostra
quando si scatta un ritratto si instaura
quasi come una relazione con chi sta
dall'altra parte dell'obiettivo che essi
siano uomini donne bambini anziani ci si
ritrova comunicare anche senza una
lingua in comune possiamo dire quindi
che unendo viaggio fotografia possono
nascere amicizie che sembrano
improbabili che cosa abbiamo in comune
con un santone indiano un pastore
afghano o una contadina cinese
l'umanità scoprire che abbiamo tutti le
stesse esigenze anche se le manifestiamo
in modo diverso
oggi la modernità e di interconnessione
tendono a renderci tutti più simili
riducendo la diversità ma esistono
ancora gruppi popoli etnie in grado di
raccontare il loro legame con il passato
anche se questo è sempre più raro
c'è chi conduce ancora una vita
completamente nome di chi sceglie di
abitare le zone più impervie del nostro
pianeta chi abita in case senza
elettricità
o acqua potabile dove il fiume il sole
la terra e gli animali sono ancora da
sempre l'unica fonte di sostentamento
ma sono mondi che stanno scomparendo per
questo penso che siano da vedere e da
raccontare perché il rischio è che di
loro non si sappia neppure che sono
esistiti e sarebbe un peccato
perché sono parte di noi anche se non li
conosciamo
proprio per questo viaggio dopo viaggio
ha preso corpo un progetto senza che
neppure avesse un nome possiamo
chiamarlo atlante dei popoli che non è
altro che la raccolta di tutte le
culture presenti sul nostro pianeta ci
sono tanti progetti di questo tipo nel
mondo
mi fa piacere citare quello di atlas of
humanity perché sono stato uno dei primi
fotografi ad esserne coinvolto dal suo
ideatore martin vega alcuni anni fa a
touch of umanità e un progetto che
riunisce un centinaia di fotografi che
lavorano ognuno per sé ma con l'intento
di documentare attraverso le proprie
fotografie la diversità nel mondo ho
aderito con grande piacere perché in
fondo il mio percorso mi stava già
portando alla realizzazione di un mio
ideale atlante dei popoli
vi faccio qualche esempio
la tribuzi in myanmar vivono nella
giungla al confine con il bangladesh il
loro fascino sta nei tatuaggi sui volti
delle donne ormai questa pratica è stata
vietata quindi è sempre più difficile
incontrare giovani donne con questo
antico ornamento la tribù kyun sempre
myanmar qui le donne sin da giovanissime
mettono collane ad anelli in oro e
ottone aggiungendone una anno dopo anno
fino a raggiungere questo collo lungo
affusolato in realtà si tratta di un
effetto ottico perché non è il collo ad
allungarsi ma le clavicole ad abbassarsi
l'etnia miao in cina
qui le donne mettono questo
caratteristico copricapo fatto da una
grossa matassa di fili di lana
intrecciata con i capelli dei loro
antenati in questa zona della cina le
popolazioni sono particolarmente
ospitali mi è stato chiesto spesso di
entrare dentro le loro case per mangiare
tutti assieme
il popolo dei net nel nord della siberia
in russia abitano la penisola dello
yamal e sono nomadi che vivono di
pastorizia e pesca vestono con queste
pelli di renna per difendersi dal gelo
che può arrivare a a meno 40 gradi
ho vissuto nelle loro tende chiamateci
qui si mangia e si dorme tutti assieme
genitori nonni figli eppure con i cani
pastore dato che il loro lavoro è molto
complesso non mi è stato chiesto di
aiutarli l'unico compito che mi è stato
dato è stato quello di tenere vivo il
fuoco e di rendere confortevole la tenda
allora rientra
la tribù dai baker one in cashmere in
india sono pastori nomadi che spostano
gli animali lungo gli impervi sentieri
himalayani una delle loro
caratteristiche principali è la barba di
questa tintura fiammeggiante con loro
vissuto una migrazione e mi è stato
chiesto di aiutarli a seguire il gregge
un po per mettermi alla prova
ma sicuramente anche per farsi due
risate
vi assicuro che non è stato proprio
affatto semplice
i monaci tibetani nella valle dello
zanskar in india siamo sempre in sugli
altopiani male jani dove ho avuto la
possibilità di entrare in un monastero
ed assistere alle loro pratiche
religiose
qui i bambini studiano per diventare
monaci ma come in tutte le parti del
mondo
ecco un pallone e la vallata si riempie
di risate
i pastori waki nel corridoio del wakan
in afghanistan
qua siamo a 4000 metri sui monti del
pamir i wacky mi hanno accompagnato
passo per passo in questo territorio
impossibile mi hanno insegnato dove
poter trovare acqua potabile come
accendere un fuoco per cucinare e dove
posizionare le tende per la notte senza
di loro mi sarei sentito sicuramente
persa
questi sono solo alcuni esempi
ma ecco perché tanto impegno per
raggiungere luoghi così remoti perché è
sempre una grande emozione raccogliere
queste testimonianze ormai ovunque anche
i confini del mondo la modernità la
tecnologia stanno arrivando e di giovani
stanno abbandonando le vecchie
tradizioni e così mi sono chiesto ma
saremmo gli ultimi a vedere quelle donne
dai volti tatuati o quei pastori di
rende e che vivono tra i ghiacci e poi
che cosa accadrà
da questa riflessione
l'idea di utilizzare la fotografia come
testimonianza ecco lo scopo più grande e
far capire quanto il mondo sia variegato
e ricco di diversità e quanto poco
sappiamo di quello che ci circonda e
alla fine abituare gli occhi e il cuore
ad aprirsi alla diversità può aiutare a
capire che la bellezza della diversità è
davvero ovunque anche a casa propria
da qui il mio interesse insieme alla
società sportiva primo gioco a far
nascere un progetto a cui tengo molto si
chiama basket inclusivo qui i bambini
giocano in gruppo senza distinzione di
maschile femminile normo dotati o
diversamente abili tutti collaborano al
gioco ed è un modo per far vivere sin da
giovanissimi la ricchezza e la bellezza
della diversità
in conclusione mi sento di dire appena
possibile torniamo a viaggiare i viaggi
non sono solo belle esperienze i viaggi
offrono qualcosa da imparare
quando si torna a casa ci si sente
cambiati non solo nei pensieri ma anche
nella consapevolezza del mondo
la diversità e bellezza arricchimento e
conoscenza apre le nostre menti ed
espande gli orizzonti
grazie
[Musica]